you mentioned two sides of the same coin
but i didn't quite understand that how
is it that developmental biology and
consciousness may be two sides because
you mentioned one is first and third
person is the other so how are they two
sides of the same coin
well in in in many ways uh first of all
uh the the fact that we all start life
as a single cell and that cell
self-assembles into a creature that can
later say i am a centralized
intelligence i am i i am a single eye a
self yeah that may be but you're made of
a bunch of cells and in fact you used to
be one cell and then a ball of cells and
so that whole process of of how that
that that's that unified self
is arranged uh and and uh supported by a
collection of of competent agents these
being cells is very similar to uh how
the body is in the pattern of the body
is is arranged by the collective
intelligence of cells morphogenesis is a
collective intelligence problem it is
not a chemistry problem or a genetics
problem it's a problem of collective
intelligence and
those same kinds of issues arise when
you're trying to understand any kind of
a
human or any other centralized
intelligence how does the information
processing and the capacities of lots of
independent subunits in the case of
brains those will be neurons but in the
case of the body there'll be other other
types of cells how do they work together
to pursue goals and plans and have
preferences that don't belong to any of
the individual subunits themselves
right the making a limb is a goal that
no individual cell can can know no no
individual cell knows what a limb is or
i can can answer the question if well
how many fingers are we supposed to have
or how long is the finger supposed to be
that is a piece of information that only
the cellular collective has right so
this ability of
pursuing large-scale goals of having and
having collective information that's
more than the sum of its parts is
exactly the same question of where does
intelligence uh and and you know sort of
uh
cognitive capacity come from those are
all
though those problems will be answered
together they will not be answered uh if
either one of these things remains
mysterious we won't have an answer to
the other